[Música]
hace tres años viví una gran aventura
dejé costa rica con mis sopas mis
hermanas y me fui a vivir a panamá
digo aventura porque todo era nuevo la
escuela los amigos la casa para más un
país maravilloso y desde el primer
momento me vestí yo con ese calor
impactante pero no solamente el calor
del clima sino también el calor de los
panameños para mamado un montón de
oportunidades y en muy poco tiempo me
hizo sentirme súper bien o pretty como
le dicen allá después de un primer año
muy positivo en panamá me puse a pensar
en cómo cuidarle de vuelta de todo lo
que haya recibido tuve una oportunidad
para hacer esto con un proyecto de
grabación de sexto grado quería escoger
un tema que fuera importante y de esa
forma hacer algo que realmente
impactaría fue ahí donde comencé a
investigar y descubrió uno de los
grandes retos pero no solamente del país
sino también del mundo entero dada mi
crianza en costa rica donde la educación
es prioritaria determine que rápidamente
que uno de los grandes retos es la
educación y en específico la deserción
estudiantil
en estos números 3 de cada 25
estudiantes costarricenses abandonaron
las aulas en el 2008 20.000 estudiantes
panameños desertaron por completo en el
2016 pero esto no es solamente un
problema costar vicencio panameño esto
es un problema mundial y para ponerles
en perspectiva 37% de todos los alumnos
latinoamericanos abandonaron las aulas
en los últimos 5 años
estas son 15 millones de vidas que
drásticamente podrían cambiar si los
estudiantes solamente se quedaran en sus
aulas pero por qué es que la decisión
estudiantil es un problema tan grande
bueno la deserción estudiantil llega a
baja calidad de vida en muchos casos
también lleva mayor pobreza pero no sólo
eso también lleva crimen y
susceptibilidad a un montón de otras
cosas como por ejemplo narcotráfico pero
esto no solamente afecta a la persona
que deserta pero afecta al país entero
porque la deserción estudiantil baja la
economía del país
yo como estudiante como parte del
sistema educativo que vive la educación
todos los días había este problema y me
puse a pensar en cómo puede arreglar lo
que yo vi que estaba fallando
antes de poder arreglar o hasta poder
resolver un algo uno tiene que entender
qué es lo que lo causa que lo que mueve
al problema
la educación tradicional solamente usa
dos sentidos para que los niños puedan
aprender la vista y la escucha también
no apela a los sentimientos de los
estudiantes no aprende esa chispita ese
fuego interno que todos tenemos cuando
estamos apasionados por algo que estamos
aprendiendo y también usualmente
aprenden con contenido lejano a donde
los estudiantes no pueden conectar lo
que aprenden a lo que viven día a día
que una metodología nueva es una
conexión crucial esto causa que muchos
pierdan interés en lo que aprenden cuál
bueno hace que deserten
esta es una de las razones por la cual
millones de estudiantes abandonan las
aulas cada año por todo el mundo pero
entonces qué podemos hacer para atacar
este problema cómo podemos preparar una
solución ahora quiero que se imaginen
que no sólo hacen motos pero múltiples
sentidos para que los niños puedan
aprender como por ejemplo el tacto y por
qué no hasta podemos apelar a los
sentimientos de los estudiantes podemos
hasta usar contenido local a donde los
niños pueden conectar lo que aprenden a
lo que viven día a día y por qué no
hacemos todo esto con algo que los niños
ya usan casi que todos los días y con
falta están familiarizados la tecnología
esto haría que muchos estén mucho más
comprometidos e involucrados en lo que
están aprendiendo cuál ya está aprobado
que hace que así que casi que muchos
estén mucho más propensos a quedarse en
escuela que no deserten
la cosa es que esto es solamente una
fórmula para poder bajar la deserción
estudiantil pero yo quería ser una
realidad y para poder hacer una realidad
decidí utilizar todo metodologías
innovadoras la primera haciendo la
realidad virtual que es cuando un niño
usa visores de 360 grados para poder
transportar es un mundo nuevo donde lo
único que hace es aprender sobre tal
materia la segunda metodología fue el
aprendiendo haciendo que es cuando un
niño puede tocar y sentir una materia
pueda estar marley y poder construirla
para poder tener un mejor entendimiento
sobre lo que está aprendiendo
bueno hasta este punto cualquier persona
podría decir que esto es completamente
teórico pero yo quería probar que sí se
puede hacer entonces lo puse en práctica
para ponerlo en práctica tuve que
hacerme tres preguntas la primera fue a
dónde a dónde se lleva peor está en
práctica la escuela omar tobío severa no
es solamente una escuela pública para
media pero también es una escuela que
está abierta ideas nuevas como por
ejemplo esta la segunda cosa que me tuve
que preguntar fue con cuáles niños
íbamos a poner está en práctica los
niños de quinto grado están a punto de
entrar la secundaria que está donde más
del 50% de cerca
la tercera cosa que me tuve que
preguntar fue sobre qué le vamos a
enseñar a estos niños cuáles materia
vamos a usar para que los niños puedan
aprender después de estudiar el temario
de quinto grado descubrí que ya aprenden
sobre diferentes etnias indígenas
panameñas y que también aprenden sobre
el canal de panamá yo pensé que sería
muy interesante para ellos poder
aprender sobre esto y también poder
aprender usando las metodologías que
acabo de decir ahora les quería enseñar
cómo es una elección con la realidad
virtual como se puede ver los niños
están completamente inmersos en lo que
están haciendo todos están parados están
haciendo la cabeza para arriba para
abajo para un lado para el otro están
transportados a la tribu indígena en
bera
y así es como se ve una lección con él
aprendiendo haciendo con él aprendiendo
haciendo se puede ver que estaban
armando la réplica del canal de panamá y
de ahí no haya ninguno que estaba ahí
sentado haciendo absolutamente nada
todos estaban contribuyendo y todos
estaban súper felices que podían
entender cómo es que funcionaba el canal
estaban completamente inmersos de lo que
estaban haciendo cuando uno es un cambio
es importante medir el impacto que tuvo
y eso es justamente lo que yo quería
hacer
a cada uno de los niños decisión
encuesta no preguntándoles sobre cuánto
habían aprendido pero cómo se compara
cómo acaban de aprender a cómo aprenden
día a día y de esa encuesta les quería
compartir te de resultados el primero
fue que el 71% dijo que ya que habían
tenido esta experiencia estaban más
interesados en ir a universidad o seguir
estudiando después un 48 por ciento dijo
que ya que sabían más pero lo que hace
ingeniero un arquitecto estaban más
interesados en esas carreras y el
tercero y el que realmente ama me
impactó a mí fue que un 91 por ciento
dijo que esta elección fue mucho más
entretenida esto me hizo sentir súper
bien porque no solamente puede obtener
los resultados que puede obtener pero
también puede probar que esto no era
solamente un sueño esto no era solamente
una teoría era la realidad y si se pudo
hacer
antes de irme los quería dejar con dos
cosas la primera es que si algo ha
cambiado en los últimos 25 años eso es
la educación antes se pensaba que la
educación era punta de leerse un párrafo
y bueno memorizar selo pero ahora hay
todo tipo de tecnologías y de
metodologías nuevas que cada día cambien
la educación y si puede ser un poco
intimidante al principio pero cuando una
la garra vale la pena y al final del día
esto esto es el futuro
estamos en un tiempo a donde no
deberíamos de esperar a que otros se
encuentren a soluciones a nuestros
problemas más no deberíamos de depender
de un gobierno o de una gran empresa
para poder hacer esto no importa la edad
género religión nada importa yo estoy
seguro de que aquí todos ustedes pueden
hacer el cambio sólo se como un cambio
de mentalidad
massa comandante una vez nos dijo a
todos tenemos que ser el cambio que
queremos ver en el mundo y ahora ahora
es el tiempo de tomar acción muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]